مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في مجزيلنباء افاد
مراسله الجزيره بوقوع دوي في جراث وتصاعد
اعمده الدخان الشرقيه ام درمان ووسطها
وبتحليق طائره حربيه في سماء مدن الخرطوم
الخرطوم بحري وام درمان وقد زاد هدون حذر
في جبهاته القتال في وقت سابق بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع بعد معارك
عنيفه امس الاحد
وقالت غرفه طوارئ جنوب الحزام بالخرطوم ان
ثمانيه عشر مدنيا قتلوا واصيب اخرون يوم
امس اجراء تساقط قذائف مدفعيه الثقيله على
احياء الازهري واستلم فور انتهاء الهدنه
استمر اطلاق المقذوفات حتى مسائل احد وفق
بياني غرفه الطوارئ
في الاثناء
بصفتهما الميسرتان لجهود وقف اطلاق النار
بالسودان اعربه عن اسى فيهما الشديد جراء
عوده طرفي القتال في السودان الى اعمال
العنف فور انتهاء فتره وقف اطلاق النار
واكدت في بين مشتركه اذا نتاهما بشده لتلك
الاعمال ودعوتهما الى وقفها فورا شدد
الجانبان على ان الحاله العسكري للصراع
غير مقبول وانهما في اطار مواصله وقوفهما
الى جانب الشعب السوداني تؤكدان الاستعداد
الاستئناف المباحثات
تعقيد منظمه الايجاد قمه اليوم في جيبوتي
تبحث قضايا افريقيه في مقدمتها الوضع في
السودان وقال الرئيس الجيبوتي ان دول
الايجاد ستدرس
اقناع طرفي الازمه في السودان اجراء حوار
كفيل بوقف اطلاق النار بشكل فعلي
قالت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه انها
استعاده السيطره على بلده
تعد هذه البلده هي الرابعه التي تعلن
القوات الاوكرانيه استعادتها منذ امس
وكانت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني اعلنت
استعاده الجيش الاوكراني السيطره على قريه
ماكاروفكا في منطقه دونيتسكا كما اعلنت
القوات الاوكرانيه استعاده السيطره على
بلدتي الشماليه
قالت قوات الجنوب في الجيش الروسي انها
صدت هجوما اوكرانيا في اتجاه
شماليه دونيس وكانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
قالت ان القوات الروسيه صدت ثمانيه هجمات
للجيش الاوكراني على محور دنيا على محور
زبالوجيا كما قالت الوزاره ان البحريه
الروسيه افشلت هجوم الاوكرانيا بزوارقه
مسيره على السفينه تابعه للاسطول الروسي
في البحر الاسود
في تايوان قالت وزاره الدفاع انها تتبعت
24 طائره عسكريه صينيه وخمسه سفن حربيه في
محيط الجزيره منذ امس الاحد وحتى الساعه
السادسه صباحا اليوم الاثنين اضفت في بيان
ان 10 طائرات دخلت منطقه تحديد الدفاع
الجوي التايوانيه
انتهى الموجز
[موسيقى]